You should never avoid or delay health care services
because of your immigration status.
I know it's not easy, right?
I know that.
But check out if you're in California,
if you're in Washington,
check out what the state is offering
in terms of free health care for everybody.
As in every other state,
there are ways in which you can seek medical attention
without avoiding it. Right?
There's clinics, there's.
You're not supposed to turn your way
because you have a medical condition.
And also, you can opt in to buy a private insurance,
so you can maybe wanna see your own doctors
or maybe you wanna see your own specialist.
Right? So look into all these avenues,
but never delay any kind of services
because of your undocumented
or because of your status or your immigration status.
All right? So if you need an assistance,
give us a call here at 81 tax Prep 5
one 6 4085528.